[Applause]
he looks like he looks like uh phil
rizzuto
yeah i'm taller than him though
well i was gonna ask you what you've
been doing with yourself since you're no
longer a manager but
now i understand this is what happens to
old time managers you're just out on a
street corner somewhere
well i want to start off by
congratulating you uh hall of fame
that's very cool thank you thank you
very much you were inducted just a few
months ago right yes uh huh
a month ago one month ago in fact here's
my hall of fame
can i see that yeah can i take it off
your finger
that's so cool this is great i can't
believe you're giving this to me
thank you and a sony look at that that's
very cool
this thing is heavy yes it's a beautiful
ring but you know it's really amazing no
you can't have it either
if i clap real loud i get to keep it
what's amazing about it is that the
baseball major league baseball
it's got a lemony taste major league
baseball has been played for 100
over a hundred years and you stop and
realize there's only 14
managers in the hall of fame at the hall
of fame you
you told the story to illustrate what a
fierce
competitor you were and uh and
and i was wanting to get you i don't
think a lot of people heard it i wanted
to hear this story again let everyone
know well you know uh
you know when the manager of a team you
got to want to win i mean uh you manage
in the major leagues
and to tell you how bad i want to win a
few years ago we were playing in
cincinnati and i got up sunday morning
and i went to church
and who came in and sat right next to me
but the manager of the cincinnati reds
johnny mcnamara sat right there
i looked at him i knew why he was in
church and he knew why i was there
and at the conclusion of the mass he and
i are walking out to center aisle
together and i'm looking at him
i'm saying man i got to beat this guy
today and as we approached the front
door he said to me very quietly he said
wait for me outside tommy i said okay
i said okay johnny i said you know where
is he going the mass is over
and i watched him he went over that side
of the church and he knelt down and he
lit a candle
and instead of me going through the
front door i went over to this side of
the church
i went in front of the altar and i
waited and when he left
i went down and blew that candle out
yes it did
i i knew one thing
i didn't think he wasn't lighting that
candle for a dead relative
and all throughout the game i kept
screaming across the village mac it
ain't going to work pal i blew it out
and we clobbered them that day 13 to 2.
and you're going to hell forever but you
won the game you know that's the
important thing
last year he last year he and his wife
ellen went the room
and he sent me a card he said try
blowing this candle out
and you got on the next concord and flew
to rome
hip check the pope you got to do
anything you can to win conan
yeah you've got to win that's the
amazing thing you're getting me into the
spirit now because i'm kind of a
i'm a pleasant guy and i like to do okay
and i work
it harder give me that okay bit mm-hmm
you know it's got
one of my players said to me one day why
do you holler at me all the time
i said because i want you to be better
than you are he said i try
i said try i get a truck driver to try
and go out on the highway get a guy
driving a truck
bring him in there and sit him down next
to you and say sir
would you try if i pay you a million
dollars a year
like this donkey's getting he would try
from three in the morning to midnight i
don't win
i don't win championships with tryers i
win with doers
don't ever tell me okay don't you ever
say that
all right all right i'm gonna go
ladies and gentlemen hey jeff how much
time is left on this show tonight
what 15 minutes i'm gonna make the next
15 minutes of this show
the best late night tv you ever saw
that's what i want to hear
this is what i want to hear don't give
me that stuff
maybe i tell him could you come by a
little more often
i tell our guys i tell my players
believe that you're the best baseball
player in the world i now believe i'm
the best baseball tell anybody about it
well tell me about this i know that you
were so committed that you were so
committed to the dodgers
that you want to take it on into the
afterlife is that right that's true tell
us this that's true
i've been with the dodgers for 48 years
and
every time a sports writer runs out of
questions they ask
he'll say to me tommy what would you
like to have put on your tombstone
and i said and i told my wife this i
said when i die
i want you to put on my tombstone in big
letters
dodger stadium was his address but every
ballpark was his home
so about 14 years ago we're in spring
training i'm out on the field they said
mr o'malley the owner
wanted to see me in the press room i
went in there and there he was with the
members of the press
his family and his friends and he made a
presentation to me
he heard me say that and he presented me
with a marble tombstone that's this high
and oh tom lasorda
a dodger and right in the middle of the
tombstone
there's a picture of a heart with a drop
of blood dripping from it painted blue
and on the bottom in letters this high
it says dodgers stadium was his address
but every ballpark was home i was so
elated
i felt honored i felt like i was the
only man in organized baseball
to receive a tombstone long before he
was to pass on
and then accepted it and then accepting
it i said to him
mr o'malley i want to go on record of
saying
to you and all these people that i want
to work for the dodgers
even when i'm dead and gone he looked at
me so wait a minute
i could understand you're saying how
much you love the dodgers but how can
you work for the dodgers when you're
dead
i said when i die i want my wife to put
the dodger home schedule on my tombstone
and when the people are in a cemetery
visiting their loved ones
they'll say let's go to lasorda's grave
to find out if the dodgers are playing
at home
or on the road wow wait
that's that's good now that's pride
yeah that's pride but it's just don't
wait but let me say this
that's pride in the organization can you
honestly tell these people tonight
that you want to do this job when you're
dead and gone
thank you pal yeah i know i would i
would do that i just think your
tombstone's getting a little cluttered i
don't know
no because can you buy merchandise on
the side of the thing
but no what i'm saying is if you can
honestly say
you would like to do this job when
you're dead then you are without a doubt
a happy person and in most cases a
successful person
i want to do this job until the end of
recorded time
you were managing a big team this is a
talk show
20 years i managed the dodgers yeah
that's right
became one of only four in the history
of the major leagues to manage the same
team for 20 years or more
and when i got this job vince scully
interviewed me
he said you're replacing a man that's
been there for 23 years
do you hope to match that record i said
buddy all i want to do is live 23 more
years
and then and then you hit him
every story ends with me thinking you're
going to hit the guy well job well done
and it was very nice to meet you mr
lasorda good to have you on the program
continued good health congratulations
communist sword everybody cyndi lauper
is coming right up we'll be right back